وننظر الى الغد لانه لانه معروف انه
الاسقاط الانظمه عن طريق الحروب اكبر ازمه
فيها انه اليوم التالي لهذا الاسقاط يبدو
انه المجتمع الدولي ما بكون عنده تصور
عليه وحاله العراق على سبيل المثال
وحالبيا اكبر دليل على ذلك الف شكر لك
للمشاركه معنا السعاده طيب
ارجو يعني من خلال حضرتك من خلال البرنامج
الرائد ومن خلال قناه العربيه وجه النداء
لاهل في ليبيا ارجوكم انسوا الماضي
انطلقوا الى الامام تكلموا على التصالح
تكلموا على السلم الاجتماعي حبوا بعضكم من
اجل ليبيا حتى اي واحد حتى كان متضرر من
اجل ليبيا لازم ان هو يوضع على الجمر
وينتقل للامام لان ليبيا هي الباقي احنا
كنا منتهيين ومنفركوش يا استاذه بس فكروا
في اولاده في المستقبل
وبكل قوه ونس الله ان هو يوفقنا لتحقيق
هذا الغايه ونسال الله ان المجتمع الدولي
ينظر الى ليبيا نظره جائزه اتمكن الشعب
الليبي من خروج من هذا الازمه ومن هذا